lizzo is on tour in support of her 2022
album special which nabbed a Grammy
nomination including a stop in November
at the Kia Forum in Inglewood throughout
the summer she'll be playing at
festivals blah blah blah and now let's
let's look at the response does anybody
hold her accountable or do they Pander
it's exhausting no matter how much you
achieve here comes the mallow content
commenting on your body and the cruelest
and stupidest ways and nothing pithy
will undo the harm just know you don't
know anyone an explanation for who you
are you're a beautiful queen you're a
beautiful kiween and other people are
ugly just trying to be seen yeah